ANWAR GHULOUM: Thanks
for coming to the talk.
We're going to talk about ART,
L's runtime replacing Dalvik.
Hopefully you'll leave,
with a better understanding
of what ART is and what
improvements you can expect.
We'll also talk a bit about
64-bit support in ART,
and in the platform at the end.
So I'll be presenting today
along with my colleagues, Brian
Carlstrom and Ian Rogers from
the Android runtime and tools
team.
I'm Anwar Ghuloum.
They'll talk about different
aspects of the runtime.
They'll be coming
up pretty shortly.
Thanks guys.
First, why ART?
So when Dalvik was
originally designed,
the processors we were
targeting were single core,
relatively poor performance,
relatively little flash
and RAM available.
But things have changed.
We had a compact bicode
that was designed
for fast interpretation,
relatively unsophisticated GC,
and it wasn't designed
for multiprocessing.
But since then, what
we've seen is we've
got phone shipping
with eight cores.
We've got devices that have
improved in performance
over the G1 by 50x or more in
terms of raw CPU performance.
We've got 4x more RAM,
sometimes more, 64x more flash,
high resolution screens,
extremely powerful GPUs.
We made a lot of changes in
Dalvik to improve things.
We added a JIT, we added a
concurrent collection garbage
collector, and we added
support for multiprocessing.
But we felt frankly, that the
ecosystem was outpacing us,
that we had to do more.
So ART was born.
So our motivation
for ART is that you
shouldn't notice
the runtime at all.
You're app should be buttery and
smooth, even though using GC.
Code should be
fast without having
to resort to JNI or native code.
Start up time should
be fast, without having
to warm up a JIT, and so on.
The runtime in
general should scale
to the parallelism
modern processors,
as well as the complexity of
modern mobile applications.
In other words, it should
be really solid foundation
for the future.
So in this talk,
we're going to start
with telling you
about performance
and compiling in ART; how
ART compiles ahead of time,
and what kind of performance
improvements that brings you.
We'll then talk about
the garbage collector
and how GCed apps can
be buttery and smooth.
And then we'll talk
a bit about 64-bit.
So with that, I'll
hand it over to Brian.
BRIAN CARLSTROM: Thanks, Anwar.
So I'm going to start
by talking about a user.
We have this public
bug that's one
of our favorites
on the ART team.
So a user wanting a
performance boosting thing.
And if you read the
details in the bug,
they want to take their existing
phone and their existing apps
and they just want to get
a system software update.
And they want faster
performance for their apps,
want better battery life.
They want to use less memories
so they can multicast more.
And we really like this
bug because it really
matches what Anwar said
about the ART manifesto,
about trying to transparently
improve performance
for apps without people
having to do anything.
So what can we do about that?
So as we've already said,
we started with Dalvik.
And it had some performance
boosting things.
It had a fast interpreter.
JIT was added, another
performance boosting thing.
And what can we do for ART?
What can we do going forward?
And we said well, Dalvik was
built for really targeting ARM.
Now in more mobile
device, modern devices,
we have a lot more ABI's
we have to support.
We want to do potentially
different optimization
levels for different use cases.
So rather than just trying to
build one performance thing,
we want to build a framework
of performance boosting things.
And so we're going to
build a flexible compiler
infrastructure that can
allow us to do that.
So this just a
little box diagram
of what we're doing
at the ART compilers.
As you'd expect,
we have a front end
that can read our dex
bicode for compilation.
We have a compiler driver,
and what's interesting
that it directs to various
different compilers that
are available in L.
We have three main compilers
that we're using in L,
but there's already seeds in the
AOSP code for other compilers
that we're working on
for the future, seeds
of future performance
boosting things.
What we have for L is a compiler
we call a quick compiler, which
is based on the old Dalvik JIT.
So it does many of
the same things,
but does more than that.
And we'll talk about
that in the next slide.
It focuses on
compiling your dex code
to native ARM code, x86
code, MIPS code, et cetera.
We also have a JNI compiler
that helps build bridges
from your dex code to
any native code you've
done within the NDK.
And finally, we have
a dex to dex optimizer
which just quickens code
we decide not to compile,
that we just want to do
fast interpretation on.
In addition, we have to
have numerous back ends,
and so we're supporting the
32 ABIs that Androis currently
supports, as well as
the new 64-bit ABIs that
are coming in L.
So what are some of
the other benefits
of doing ahead of
time compilation?
One big difference between
ahead of time compilation
and the JIT we had in
Dalvik is that we optimized
the whole program potentially
and instead of just focusing
on small traces of the program,
loops, or things like that.
So the kind of
optimizations you did
when you're targeting like small
parts the program, or loops,
are very different
than when you're
trying to do the whole program.
And we try to do optimizations
that can generally apply
to all kind of object
oriented programming
that you might be
doing in Android.
And so some examples are, we
try to make virtual method calls
faster when possible,
we try to lower
the overhead for
interface and vacations,
we try to avoid some
implicit checks that
need to be done
when you're calling
from one class to another to
make sure it's initialized,
and when you're calling
constructors or static fields.
So exercising site fields, or
calling [INAUDIBLE] methods.
And finally, there's
a lot of things
are sort of implicit
checks that are done.
Not just growing
languages, that there
are no pointers,
and uncommon cases,
and StackOverflow,
and things like that.
So we try to make all those
kind of common case things
faster so we can improve
the general performance
of your program.
But we've also seen
some other benefits
from of ahead of
time compilation.
Those things that
the user wanted.
We do see better battery
life, and there's
two reasons for that.
One is because we're compiling,
and only in the installation
time, we compile once
as opposed to a JIT
based environment where every
time you run the program,
it typically re-JITs,
rediscovers things,
redoes work.
It's kind of wasteful every
time you run your program
through doing the
same compilations.
Second thing we see is that
generally faster performing
code saves battery because
you can more efficiently run
and get back to a lower state
on the processor quicker.
We also see a better
Svelte memory.
Remember Project
Svelte from last year,
trying to run better on
lower memory devices.
The reason we see
better Svelte numbers
are because the code
is written out to disc,
and can be paged in and out
by the kernel on demand.
If there's a lot of applications
running, multitasking,
the kernel can kind of manage
paging things in and out,
as opposed to the
JIT, where there
would be a kind of set of
private pages per application
which couldn't be paged out.
So that meant that if the kernel
needed to free up more memory,
it basically has
to kill a process,
and you lose one
of your processors
you maybe are trying
to multitask between.
So how do we do that?
This shows the life cycle of an
APK, the Android package that
comes from developers
to the users.
And so the typical steps in
the APK, a life in a life cycle
are, you take your source code.
You compile it, you
make a dex file,
and can combine it
with native code
from the NDK and resources,
and you basically put in a zip
file we call the APK.
And that gets distributed
through Google Play
to the user.
So on the user
side they take it,
and they install
the application.
And the native code
and the resources
generally get packed unpacked
into the application directory.
But the dex code requires
further processing.
And this is true both for Dalvik
and for ART, as you see here.
In Dalvik, they ran it
through a tool called dexopt
during installation,
which is some already
did some ahead of
time things that ahead
of time class verification.
Again, try to quicken things
up to improve performance
for the interpreter.
Dex to ODE is the
tool that ART uses.
And again, this is sort of
transparent behind the scenes.
But it compiles the
application in addition
to doing some of that Dalvik
did in terms of verifying
things ahead of time,
and quickening things,
it also does that compilation
to native code for the target
for the particular device.
And the key takeaway
here is that
from a developer's point of
view and a user's point of view,
kind of the flow of how
the APK works is the same.
And hopefully, you're just
going to get faster, a better
experience.
This is a little
bit of a picture
of what it looks like when
you're running the dex tool
inside if you were
inside of a tool.
We actually start up
a minimal run time
that loads the
framework code and some
of the commonly used
framework objects
so that when we
compile the code,
we kind have an idea of what the
Android system you're running
on looks like so we
can make optimization
specific to that target device.
So once we kind of initialize
this framework environment,
we then go ahead and
load the compiler
and load the coder compiler
of your application,
and generate an ELF file.
So what does this
ELF file look like?
Sorry, yeah.
This is the ELF,
kind of an overview
of what these files looks like.
ELF is a standard file
format for representing
executable code.
It is a standard file.
We have kind of the
sections you want to expect.
We have a symbol table,
we have read only data.
We have some text that
contains the actual code.
One difference between how we
use ELF files in more of a C,
C++ kind of language would use
them is we don't use symbols
to find every
single entry point.
Because typically a Java
program has many, many methods.
And having a symbol for each
one as unique would be too big.
So instead, we use the
things that are already
in the next dex bicode,
type indexes and method IDs
to identify things.
And we have this old data
structure that we instead
look up using the symbols
in the symbol table.
And once we have that
data structure loaded,
we can quickly navigate
when we're loading a class
to find all the methods
for a particular thing
and link them up so we can
execute the code quickly.
One other thing that we do
that's a little bit different
is we actually keep the
original dex files around
in the metadata in the ELF file.
We use that first
sort of the class meta
data for loading classes.
You also use it
for other purposes,
such as when you want to run
the debugger and single stuff,
your code.
We keep the original code
around so we can give you
an accurate
debugging experience.
One final thing to note here
is that in a compiled code
for the class on the
box at the bottom,
you can see it
actually does have
direct links into framework
code as well framework objects,
so we can efficiently
call things
and not have to do runtime
lookups to find references
to framework's code, which
generally speeds application
execution.
So this is just
kind of a time based
view of what a
compilation looks like.
On the lower left,
we have a systrace
of a compilation of
a pretty meaty app.
It's running on a
four core device.
And I've tried to break out the
colored boxes on the lower left
there to the right so you can
kind of get an idea of what's
going on there, and
I'll talk through that.
You can see most
of it actually does
get good parallelism
during compilation.
That's part of taking more
advantage of the modern devices
whereas the dexopt and
and other tools for Dalvik
were more single threaded.
So we do have a serial face at
the beginning, where we extract
out the dex files
for processing.
But then we do a pass, most
of the passes are parallel.
And the first pass
is class resolution,
where basically load
all the classes,
load their fields and methods.
And this is where
the compiler learns
what the layout of a class is,
what the label of the v table
is for the methods in the
class so we can again, use
that later on
during compilation.
The next phase is
class verification.
We walk through the
bike codes of the class.
For most almost all
methods we encounter,
we find that they
are verified, and we
can mark that class as verified.
And again, skip doing
that during every runtime.
One other thing we
do, there are cases
where we have failures
during verification.
So for example, if you
install an APK that's
maybe meant for the L release,
and you install it on KitKat,
you may reference new
APIs from the L release.
And so we deal with that by
noticing this [INAUDIBLE]
is a soft failure
during verification,
we mark that one
thing and so later
on when the compiler
compiles, it
can know that well, I'm not
sure if this code is avialable
or not and put a slower
path in so that we
can do the correct
thing and handle it
if the code accidentally goes
down this path of calling
a method that doesn't actually
exist in this release.
So if all that passes,
we do this pass
called the initialization pass.
And we actually check
for any method, or sorry,
any class that was
probably verified.
If it all verified OK and
has no class initializer,
we'll go ahead and mark it
as initialized ahead of time
so that we know when
we're compiling code
that references that class, that
we don't have to do any class
initialization checks.
Again, another optimization
for object only programming.
And so finally
you can see, we've
spent not quite half the time.
But a lot of time in
the program down there
through that purple section
during verification, and now we
finally start to do compiling.
And this is where the compiler
driver takes over and directs
the different methods
to different compilers
potentially, choosing to compile
for native code or JNI bridges,
or just doing dex to dex
for things were not commonly
run class initializers.
We don't waste time or
space compiling it out.
So finally, we have
a link step where
we combine all the references
between the compiled code
any references to the
framer's code and metadata.
And then we link that together,
and we write our own ELF file.
So what does this get us?
So this is the slide
from yesterday's keynote
I wanted to go into a
little bit more detail.
You can see here
the blue bars are
the Dalvik JIT as a baseline.
This is our Nexus 5,
kind of an AOSP build
from recently around
L snapshot time.
The red bar show
the ART performance.
And then you can see our
collection of common benchmarks
we are doing better
than the Dalvik JIT.
The lowest number there is
the AnTuTU composite score.
And I wanted to just talk
about the for a second.
Because the composite,
it's a composite
of some things that
are running dex code,
and some things that are
running native codes.
We can only get
improvement on the parts
of that composite benchmark
that are running dex code.
And then we do get some
improvement on those areas.
A lot of the other
benchmarks, you
can see we have this general
kind of bars of improvement.
Many of those are kind of
these historical benchmarks,
like Drystone, or ford porter
from C or Fortran or something.
And they're not really
written in a Java style.
What we really like is
the chest bench score,
because that's actually more
reflective of an Android
developer writing functionary
code in a modern way
where the benefits they'll see.
And I think hopefully
that's more representative
of what you'll see for
most applications doing
kind of compute in Android.
So with that. just a reminder.
This is kind of a snapshot
of where we are now.
We have additional work
we've been doing in AOSP
that hopefully some of
that will make it into L,
so we'll have more performance
boosting things before we ship.
And with that, I
want to introduce
Ian Rogers, whose going to
talk about other performance
boosting things, the
ART garbage collectors.
IAN ROGERS: Thank you, Brian.
So-- very loud.
So I'm going to talk
about garbage collection,
and basically how we're going
to achieve fast allocation.
What we've been really
focusing on less junk,
giving you a buttery experience
when you're using Android,
and minimizing the
memory footprint.
So what is the memory
manager trying to do?
We're trying to allocate
objects inside a application.
We need to track on
behalf of the application
whether those objects are still
in use, whether they're alive.
And need to reclaim them when
they're no longer in use.
We want to do all this and
we want to do it for free.
And this is a real advantage
in the Android ecosystem
is that this burden is taken
away from the developer.
So let's think about
memory management schemes.
There's no approach
which is free.
If you have native
code, you have
to worry about when
you're allocating objects
when you're going
to reclaim them.
You have to worry about
complex data structures which
might have cycles in them.
You have to worry about
multi-threaded issues
like when an object says
accessed by multiple threads.
So there are costs
associated with that.
If you're using
reference counting,
than you can find that a
thread that lowers a reference
count suddenly ends
up having to reclaim
all of the garbage in
the known universe.
And all of these things
can create a lot of work
on an application thread
and cause significant junk
and problems for the
application developer.
So what we've been
focusing on in ART
is making GC
something that doesn't
get in the way of
the application
and doesn't get in the way
of the application developer
so they're freed from
worrying about it.
And our principal consideration
has been how to reduce junk.
And this comes around
from post times
from the garbage collector.
And I'll go into
detail about that.
So let's look at what's going
on inside a garbage collection.
Here, we have some threads
though, the wiggly lines.
We have a heap, which
is the rectangle.
And inside the heap are
green and red rectangles
indicative of live objects
which are objects which
are in use by the application
and dead objects, which
are objects that the application
can no longer access.
The blue object on
the left is an object
that we're trying to allocate.
So the job that the garbage
collector's got to do
is at allocation time, it's
got to find places for objects
to fit in to get allocated.
And it's also a GC time,
it's got to go and find
all of these live objects,
these green objects.
And having found
all of them, it then
has to go and free them up.
So let's see what happens
inside of a Dalvik.
When we're going and
finding this initial set
of live objects, Dalvik
will suspend the application
threads.
It also suspends threads
inside of the virtual machine.
So we tend to refer
to these threads
as a whole as mutator threads.
They mutate the state
of the Java heap.
And to do this, Dalvik
suspends these threads
so that it can crawl
less stacks and find
what objects those
stacks are referencing.
Once it's determined, this
initial reachable set,
it then traverses it
in a concurrent phase.
So the garbage
collector is running
alongside the application.
Once it's found
all of the objects,
it then goes and
does another pause.
The reason for this
pause is to make sure
that the application
wasn't playing
any games with the
garbage collector
and hiding objects which the
garbage collector thought
it had already processed.
In this phase, the
card table will
be examined by the
garbage collector.
Finally, having determined that
everything has been marked,
the garbage collector
restarts all the threads,
and it concurrently
sweeps and frees up
the object which were allocated.
So in Dalvik, the pauses
have been highly optimized.
And the first pause is
around 3 to 4 milliseconds,
and the second pause is
around 5 to 6 milliseconds.
But the sum total of that
is about 10 milliseconds.
If we're going to achieve
60 frames per second,
we need to be able to run the
frames in 16 milliseconds.
And taking 10 milliseconds
for garbage collection
pauses out of that
60 milliseconds
means we get dropped frames.
So here is an assist trace of
Dalvik running the Google Play
store.
And we're doing
a fling, so we're
scrolling down and allowing
lots of bitmaps to scroll by.
And the bitmaps
are causing objects
to get created, and
caught, and triggering GCs.
And at the top,
you can see what's
running on each individual CPU.
Beneath this are
the vsync events,
which are the screen
refresh events.
Below this, we have the
vending application,
the name of the Play
Store application.
And its rendering
frames, and you
can see that in the dark green.
And ideally, what we would
see is with every vsync event,
there would be some dark green.
But you can see in the sensor
here that the dark green isn't
there, and that's because
of a dropped frame.
It was causing a drop frame.
At the bottom,
we've got the view
of what's going on
inside of Dalvik.
And we can see that
there are GCs going on.
They're explicit GCs
going on back to back.
Another pauses within this.
And we can see that the
second pause came in just
before the vsync event where
we had the dropped frame.
So this isn't good.
This isn't giving us the buttery
experience you want on Android.
And one of the things
that was on that systrace,
we saw that GC cycles were
happening back to back.
And why was this happening?
Well, the application was
trying to avoid a pathology.
And kind of what happens
in Dalvik's behavior
where Dalvik is trying to
avoid a heap fragmentation
and allowing the heap
to grow, because it's
worried about large
objects getting reclaimed,
and then small objects coming in
and fragmenting the heap making
it so that the wrong places
where large objects can
come and fit into the heap.
So this is kind of shown
on this graphic here.
We've got the large blue object.
We failed to find
somewhere to fit it.
We're worried about
fragmentation,
and so Dalvik is going to
suspend all of the application
threads and do it
a GC for our log,
to then go and free up all
of the objects it can so
hopefully, do a
better job at fitting
this large object into the heap.
What does that look like
for the application?
It looks like one large pause.
And these pauses are typically
around 50 milliseconds.
So this is going to translate
into four dropped frames.
Here, we can see again, a
systrace of a Google Maps
application this time.
And we can see that's
we've got two GCs happening
at the bottom.
And for in this
situation, the two GCs
have caused a pause of around
60 milliseconds, and 4 to 5
dropped frames.
So for us, everything
is awesome.
We fixed all the problems.
Open bugs, if we haven't.
Please
[APPLAUSE]
So we've made the
garbage collector faster
by new backup
collection algorithms.
We've reduced the
number of causes
and made the causes
themselves shorter.
We've taken ergonomics
decisions and strategies
to reduce the amount
of fragmentation
so that we no longer
need the GC for analog.
And we've done all
of this with support
for things like
moving and compacting
collectors and ways that
allow us to use less memory.
So what do pauses look like in
the ART's garbage collector?
Going back to the
earlier graphic,
we've got rid of
the first pause.
What we do to create this
initial set of objects
that the garbage collector
needs to traverse
is the garbage
collector requests
that the applications go
and mark their own stacks.
So this is a very short thing
for the application threads
to do.
And after they've done it,
they can carry on running.
So there's no need to suspend
all of the applications
threads.
So this checkpointing, as it
gets called gets done first,
and the garbage
collector waits for that.
And then it enters
the concurrent phase
that we had before
in the Dalvik CMS
asking where we're going
to mark all of the objects.
Then we have the second pause.
And we've managed to
make pause a lot shorter
than the Dalvik pause.
We've done this by tricks like
[INAUDIBLE] cleaning where
we take work out of the
pause and do it ahead of it,
and then we just
double check that
what we did before
the pause was correct.
If we look at systrace, this is
going back to the Google Play
Store application,
and doing a fling.
We've got the vsync events
and frames being rendered.
We've got a garbage
collection pause
happening just where the
single pause is indicated.
And no dropped frames.
The other thing that you
can see on this systrace
is that the GCs aren't
occuring, the back
to back GCs that was coming
in the Play Store before.
And that's because ART doesn't
suffer from the fragmentation
problems that Dalvik had.
And so we now trigger, treat
the system GCs as something
are optional, and we
only use them as a hint
that we should trigger a
garbage collection cycle.
Whereas with Dalvik,
they would always
trigger a concurrent
garbage collection cycle.
And so there are no
dropped frames here.
And that single pause is
measuring about 3 milliseconds.
So that was kind of a lot
faster than the pauses
that you're seeing in Dalvik.
So how did we get rid of
the GC for analog events?
So the problem we were having in
Dalvik was these large objects
were coming in.
And these large objects would
be bitmaps in the common case.
And so what we do in ART
is we move the bitmaps out
of the main heap, and put them
into their own separate, still
part of the managed heap.
But it's a separate area in
the managed heap especially
dedicated to large arrays
of primitive objects.
And this is also useful
for us, because we
know that by definition, a
raise of primitive objects
don't have references
to other objects.
And so we can improve the
bookkeeping and the performance
of the garbage collector
as a consequence.
What does this look
like for an application
like for Google Maps?
So on the left, we've
got the concurrent marks
GCs happening in Dalvik.
The first pause, around
3 to 4 milliseconds,
the second pause around
5 to 6 milliseconds.
And total coming in at
just under 10 milliseconds.
These are times from a Nexus 4.
The GC for analogs,
which typically
taking the average one was
around 54 milliseconds.
And so that translates into
a lot of dropped frames.
What is ART looking like
in the same test scenario?
Well the average
pauses are coming
in at 2 and 1/2 milliseconds.
So that's around
four times faster.
We've also found that
one of the areas where
we needed to improve was
in terms of our allocation
performance.
So we were working with the
Google Spreadsheets team
internally inside of Google,
and they were really excited
by ART, because they've
been experiencing
some bad performance.
And so they switched
over to using ART,
but they didn't realize
that the full performance
that they were expecting to see.
So you can see that
on this bar chart.
On the left normalized to one
is the Dalvik performance.
And when they switched
over to using ART,
they managed to get
a 25% performance
improvement on a Nexus 4.
However, they wanted more.
They wanted the 2X.
They wanted the 4X.
So there were other things we
did in ART, having seen this.
So one of the things was
we started specializing
the allocation paths so that
the allocation paths cannot
allocate certain classes of
objects faster than others
by knowing things like the size
of the object ahead of time.
And this achieved
a performance win,
but not the dramatic performance
win we would really have liked.
So the next thing that
we did was something
that we'd wanted to
do for a long time.
And we implemented our
own memory allocator.
So Dalvik and ART
in KitKat we're
basing on top of Doug Lea's
memory allocator, which
is the common one used
in Unix's and so on.
And this supports
a [INAUDIBLE] free,
but it's not really
tuned for Java,
and it's not really tuned for
a multi-threaded environment.
So to make sure that it
behaves in a correct manner,
it has a single
global lock around it.
And so the garbage collector
could be freeing things,
and that would conflict
with the application trying
to allocate objects.
And you had multiple allocations
happening at the same time,
then they would get
run sequentially.
The rosallac, as we call it,
the rows of slots allocator,
has a number of optimizations
to improve performance.
The first of which,
is the small objects,
the small temporary
objects that is
so useful in
languages like Java.
They get allocated in
a thread local region.
And so because the
region is thread local,
this means that
allocations can occur
with no locking and no kind
of sequential behavior.
For larger objects, the
bends that they fit into
have their own individual locks.
So again, it's reducing the
contention for the locks,
and is a lot more parallelism.
This is translated into a huge
performance for this benchmark,
and you can see that
the memory allocation
performance has improved 10x.
So we've been working on a
number of different garbage
collection algorithms for ART.
We're making ART
into a framework
that developers and partners
can come along and contribute
to and improve upon.
The first new garbage
collector that ART added
was a sticky garbage collector.
The sticky garbage collector
takes advantage of the fact
that we can know
what objects were
allocated since
the last GC cycle.
And because the generational
hypothesis tells us
that these objects are
the most likely to be
useful to be freed up, then
we focus our energy on these.
And because garbage
collection at the time
is proportional to the
amount of live data
we're going to
process, and we're
going to process less
because we're only
going to consider the live
data since the last GC,
the sticky GC is typically
running 2x or 3x faster
than the current
garbage collector,
and reclaiming the
same amount of memory.
When the sticky garbage
collector can't run,
we run the regular CMS collector
for either the applications
heap, or the applications
heap in the zygote.
And the ratio between running
the sticky garbage collector
and the regular concurrent
garbage collector,
we tend to run the sticky
one five times for every one
time we need to run
the partial one.
We're also working on
moving garbage collectors
where this slide comes in.
And what are moving
garbage collectors?
So moving garbage
collectors, they
want to do the
same reset creation
and marking of objects.
But what they want to do
during the sweeping phase
is they want to move all
of those objects together.
And this basically removes all
of the fragmentation and so on.
We do this in ART
via two approaches.
We have a semi space
garbage collector
where we create a
new memory region,
and we evacuate the
objects out of a heap
and into that newly
created space.
And we also have a
mock compact algorithm
that's coming online
at the moment where
we compact things in place.
So moving collectors are good.
There's less fragmentation,
it saves heap.
The downside to them
is that if you're
going to be moving
objects around,
the effects of
moving an object has
to be seen by the
application atomically.
There are two approaches
you can take to doing this.
You can introduce read barriers
so that the read barrier
handles the fact that the object
is moving around in the heap.
Or the most common
approach is just
to suspend all of the
application threads again.
And this isn't good from
a GC junk point of view.
So we want to use the moving
collector to compact the heap
and get these memory savings.
So when can we do it?
So we know certain
things about how
applications run in Android.
We know that it's
worthwhile to compact
the heap joined zygote startup.
Because if we save
space in the zygote,
we're going to save it
for every application
after the Android runtime is up.
The other place we
can use COMPAxiON
is when applications
go into the background,
so when you press
the Home screen.
And so we have
various ergonomics
determining when is
a good idea to run,
to switch the garbage collector
over to a compacting algorithm.
We have various
means of determining
whether an application
can perceive junk.
We don't want to do things
like have the Play music
application, which isn't a
foregrounded application.
We don't want to
have junk in that,
because that would
give you choppy audio.
And so hopefully we've
done our jobs right,
and it's all working, and so on.
And so you'll get
less memory usage.
So with that, let
me hand back Anwar.
ANWAR GHULOUM: All right.
Thanks Ian.
So a few words about 64-bit
support coming with L.
So it's one of the major
features of L. Partners
have been shipping, or
readying to ship 64-bit SFZs,
and we're working
pretty closely with them
to make 64-bit userspace happen.
So why 64-bit?
Well you might
argue that we don't
need the additional
address space now,
but if you look at
the keynote yesterday,
Android usage is
diversifying pretty rapidly
from wearables to TVs.
And bearing in mind,
I think it's really--
and there's definitely value
today in supporting 64-bit.
We see nice performance
gains in 64-bit apps
running on 64-bit capable cores.
There are new instructions,
domain specific instructions
for media encrypto, where
we get huge speedups that
can benefit the entire platform.
But even in general
purpose apps,
we're seeing nice speedups.
So we'll take a
look at that first,
and then I'll get
into a few details
of how we make this work.
So as I said, we spec
compute intensive stuff
to take biggest
advantage of this.
We're working closely with ARM,
with Intel, MIPS, Qualcomm,
and others to make sure that
we really deliver on this.
So what I'm showing
you here is graphs
of speedup of 64-bit
apps over 32-bit apps
on the same silicon.
On upper left hand side
as you face the screen,
I'm showing you speedup
in terms of a multiplier.
This is on Intel's Bay Trail.
Processor's a four core SOC
for some custom render script
scripts.
And we're seeing some
really nice speedups
going to 64-bit
up to and over 4x.
For crypto, we use open SSL's
a primary crypto engine.
If you look at ARM64 support,
ARMv8 support on Cortex A53
and Cortex A57 for the
open SSL speed benchmark,
we're seeing some really
nice speedups there as well.
Again, this is used throughout
the entire platform.
Any applications that's
using Android crypto
is probably going to
benefit from this.
And again, those are multipliers
on the vertical axis sourcing
about, a 15x improvement there.
And even for native stuff, we're
seeing some nice improvements.
Panorama benchmark
is a benchmark
that we use internally to
evaluate tool chain updates.
It's meant to be
representative of a user taking
a bunch of photos and then
waiting for them to get
stitched together in a
nice little panorama.
What we see here is that on
Cortex ARMS, Cortex A53 and A57
cores simply recompiling
it for 64-bit,
we see up to 20%
boost for this one.
That means the end user
is sitting there waiting
for a panorama, and
happens 20% faster.
But it also uses 20% less power
probably in terms of CPU core.
And that's a really nice thing.
But what about ART?
So for ART, we
weren't really looking
for big performance
gains of 64-bit.
Obviously we were
hoping, but we've
been pleased with what
we've seen thus far.
We expected most of this
again, to come again
in the computer
intensive workloads.
So looking at ART performance
here, this is on Baytrail.
We have on the left,
speedups of going
to ART 32-bit from
Dalvik 32-bit.
So they're getting some really
nice speedups on spec JVM
up to over 6x.
But the cherry on
top is that we get up
to another 30% speedup
going to 64-bit.
And again, all these
numbers, it's early days.
There's a lot more
tuning that we're
going to be doing for 64-bit
with ARM Intel and MIPS.
So expect more to
come from this.
OK, so how are we
getting this done?
Well, as Brian mentioned, we
have compilers for 64-bit,
for x86 64, for ARM64,
and MIPS64 coming soon.
We've extended the zygote
model for app creation
by having dual zygotes.
So we have a zygote
for 32-bit apps,
and a zygote for 64-bit apps.
What happens when you
launch an app or a service,
we detect what ABI it needs,
or what ABIs it can use,
and then we delegate to that
zygote to start up the app.
So what that means is that, and
I'll say more about this later,
is that your apps,
you're 32-bit apps
are still going to work
in your 64-bit device.
The other thing we
were concerned about
is memory bloat.
How much more
memory is this going
to take having two zygotes, and
then having 64-bit references?
Well in ART, we're using
compressed references.
We're using just 32 bits for
object references on the heap.
So that mitigates
some of this concern.
So the cool thing about
this is that if you
have an application that's just
running on ART, that's just
dex code written in Java or
whatever, it'll just work.
As long as there's no native
code you can download that app,
and if you have a 64-bit device,
it'll run on the 64-bit VM.
That's 85% of apps in Play
Store that are immediately
64-bit ready.
Developers don't
need to recompile,
they don't need to upload
a new version or whatever.
It just works, and it's
ready for you for free
when you get your new device.
So another performance
boosting thing
that ART and L and our SSE
partners are bringing you.
The other thing is that
we'll be shipping NDK support
And RenderScript support
for 64-bit with L as well.
So you can take advantage of
all that other compute intensive
stuff as well.
OK, so to learn more
about ART, there's
a couple of articles you should
check out on android.com.
The first one,
"Introducing ART,"
covers some of the same ground
that we've covered here.
The second one, "Verifying
App Behavior on ART,"
goes into more
detail on how ART can
help you find bugs
in your application.
Especially around J&I,
you should definitely
check that out.
And with that, we'll
take questions.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Can I start off?
ANWAR GHULOUM: Yeah, go for it.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
So I was wondering
how ART is going
to jive with byte code injection
that might happen right
after compilation
or even at runtime.
ANWAR GHULOUM: Go ahead.
BRIAN CARLSTROM: No.
I'll let you do it.
IAN ROGERS: So, maybe I'll--
ANWAR GHULOUM: Oh, yeah.
IAN ROGERS: OK.
So the model that Dalvik
has and ART continues
is that for class loaders,
we have to have everything
that the class loader
has backed up by a file.
So Dalvik never had supports
for the kind of doing end memory
injection of
instructions, and so on.
If you have a file on
the disk, then this
is something we can do
ahead of time compilation
for and put into our
cache so that we're not
regenerating it all of the time.
So basically, it works the
same way as with Dalvik.
There might be a
little bit more time
when we're doing
the compilation so
that you might notice something
at the initial startup, a pause
at startup, because
of the compilation.
But our compilation times are
really good and really fast, so
hopefully imperceptible.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thanks.
ANWAR GHULOUM: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: What's the
effect on the boot
time compared to Dalvik?
ANWAR GHULOUM: So first boot
when we're compiling things,
things can slow down a bit.
Compile time takes a bit
longer, and the scale things
we're really talking
about is an app
goes from taking one
second to DEX-HOP to say,
2 and 1/2, 3 seconds to DEX-HOP.
But if you're doing
that over many apps.
it adds up.
That's just at first boot,
or after an OTA, which
are relatively
infrequent events.
In general, we think
boot time will be faster.
The one mitigating
thing though is
because we're doing COMPAxiON
boot time, to really make
the heap more efficient.
There is potential
to extend things.
Although recently, I
think a patch went up too
to optimize that
down, it'll only
do the COMPAxiON sort
of toward the end
so we're not
extending boot time.
But code should be faster,
starting up system services
and so on should be faster.
And things should
just be faster.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.